Caption: as well he's typing the password in off
Caption: screen
Caption: I'll introduce you to Damien he runs the
Caption: developer advocacy at GitHub and loves
Caption: all things devops formerly a cloud
Caption: Advocate at Microsoft for four years and
Caption: prior to that a devot octopus deploy and
Caption: and Microsoft MVP Damien has 20 plus
Caption: year background in software development
Caption: and Consulting in a broad range of
Caption: Industries he regularly speaks at
Caption: conferences just like this
Caption: user groups and other events around the
Caption: world sorry that was mean
Caption: this is not this is not his fault just
Caption: just like this actually
Caption: so let's give Damien a big long welcome
Caption: as he sets himself up
Caption: this is going well
Caption: um
Caption: I'm going to skip all my slides because
Caption: that's a boring bit anyway
Caption: um and I'm just going to go straight to
Caption: demo so
Caption: my name is Damian Brady I work at GitHub
Caption: I lead our developer advocacy team
Caption: um I came from Microsoft I've talked
Caption: about devops for years
Caption: um this time I'm going to be talking
Caption: about devops in terms of doing it all on
Caption: codes on sorry on GitHub
Caption: right so we're going to be going from
Caption: planning and tracking all the way
Caption: through to the inner loop like actually
Caption: writing code in the cloud on code spaces
Caption: and then actions to deploy like with a
Caption: CI CD pipeline all the way through to
Caption: the end all right now
Caption: I started about 15 minutes late so let's
Caption: see how quickly we can do this if I skip
Caption: over stuff and you're like I really want
Caption: to know more about that we have all of
Caption: this demo stuff at the GitHub Booth as
Caption: well so come and have a look the
Caption: difference in the GitHub Booth though is
Caption: that everything's running off a
Caption: Raspberry Pi so I'm doing
Caption: multi-container development debugging
Caption: and stuff but my Dev machines this
Caption: Raspberry Pi hanging from a carabiner
Caption: next to the TV
Caption: we'll see some of that in a sec not the
Caption: Raspberry Pi but the code spaces right
Caption: so devops you've all seen that kind of
Caption: uh sideways eight like the infinity
Caption: symbol that we talk about with devops
Caption: where we do plan you know build deploy
Caption: and then learn from that the idea with
Caption: devops being that you can get through
Caption: that whole like infinity symbol as
Caption: quickly as possible so get stuff out to
Caption: production as quickly as possible so you
Caption: can learn from it and work out what
Caption: needs to be done next right
Caption: um what I'm going to focus on today is
Caption: everything from the plan bit all the way
Caption: through to production right we're not
Caption: really going to talk so much about the
Caption: learning from it
Caption: um GitHub doesn't have a product for for
Caption: you know looking at metrics of things
Caption: that are going on in production we do
Caption: have awesome kind of tooling around
Caption: discussions with your communities and of
Caption: course there's GitHub issues that can be
Caption: open so the community can contribute as
Caption: well or your customers can contribute as
Caption: well to what you're doing but we're not
Caption: going to really cover that that part so
Caption: much Beyond just issues
Caption: all right I'm already talking too much
Caption: let's go and have a look you can see a
Caption: little bit about some of the security
Caption: stuff that's built in here as well
Caption: um dependabot has told me that my code
Caption: has security vulnerabilities
Caption: which is deliberate I promise
Caption: um I'm just going to ignore them at the
Caption: moment which is also deliberate oh this
Caption: is going to be fun your scroll things
Caption: reverse of what I usually use
Caption: yeah I'm playing in hard mode all right
Caption: who who's familiar with GitHub issues
Caption: yep okay cool if you're not GitHub
Caption: issues is kind of the way that we track
Caption: a piece of work so issues the word issue
Caption: as we use it is a thing that we need to
Caption: care about ultimately it's fine I'll
Caption: work it out
Caption: um
Caption: okay oh yeah
Caption: um it's it's a thing we need to care
Caption: about right it's not uh a bug it's not a
Caption: synonym for a bug although you can
Caption: absolutely track your bugs using GitHub
Caption: issues we use issues internally for
Caption: everything at GitHub so we in our devrel
Caption: organization we have a repository that
Caption: has very little code in it but it we use
Caption: issues to track all of the work that
Caption: everybody is doing the whole way through
Caption: and you'll see some of the planning and
Caption: tracking tools and why it's it's
Caption: valuable to do that regardless of
Caption: whether they're actual pieces of code
Caption: that you need to change or not so the
Caption: GitHub issues um UI when you go to the
Caption: issues tab in GitHub you'll just get
Caption: this list of all of the issues that are
Caption: in there you know categorized by open
Caption: and closed you can do some great
Caption: searching and filtering and stuff like
Caption: that apply labels all that kind of thing
Caption: um and so the the experience with
Caption: actually creating issues and using
Caption: issues is pretty good too so if we
Caption: create an issue
Caption: um
Caption: you know you can give it a title uh
Caption: what's a title fix that laptop output
Caption: which is a good one
Caption: um and then you can you know put a whole
Caption: lot of detail about
Caption: um
Caption: stuff what's the screenshotting Windows
Caption: Windows shift s
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah I'm a pro
Caption: um
Caption: you can even do things like paste images
Caption: uh wrong Keys uh you can even like copy
Caption: and paste images so I just took a
Caption: screenshot and then
Caption: the preview can see that screenshot that
Caption: I just took so you can copy paste images
Caption: you can do rich markdown formatting all
Caption: that kind of stuff there's some really
Caption: good features around task lists too so
Caption: you can set a list of you know things
Caption: you need to do
Caption: second thing and then
Caption: when you save or submit that issue just
Caption: get rid of that last one
Caption: you can see that there's a task list
Caption: attached to this issue as well
Caption: and we can see that there are two tasks
Caption: for that issue that need to be done and
Caption: maybe I want to say I've done the first
Caption: thing but maybe the second thing needs a
Caption: little bit more work and so I can just
Caption: need to refresh ah wrong buttons F5
Caption: no that's all right see this is why I
Caption: have a desktop PC at home and a Macbook
Caption: so I know both of them anyway so the
Caption: second one maybe I want to actually
Caption: convert that to an issue because it
Caption: needs some more expansion notes and more
Caption: details when I do that it'll create an
Caption: issue from that second thing and if I
Caption: drill into that issue we can see that
Caption: that is tracked in one of the previous
Caption: issues so we have this kind of hierarchy
Caption: the hierarchy stuff in GitHub issues is
Caption: still kind of being built out it'll be a
Caption: lot richer in the future right now we we
Caption: kind of do have this hierarchy between
Caption: and you can go down as deep as you want
Caption: if I did a task list in this and
Caption: converted them to issues you can see
Caption: that it's tracked in those ones as well
Caption: that stuff will start surfacing a bit
Caption: more soon
Caption: so we've got our issues we can do real
Caption: really rich markdown we can even do like
Caption: mathematical formulas and we use um
Caption: tooling to do flow charts and stuff like
Caption: that you can put in there in markdown
Caption: it's this GitHub flavored markdown that
Caption: we have which is a little bit richer
Caption: but this probably isn't the best way to
Caption: like manage all of your issues you might
Caption: have thousands of issues
Caption: you can't really run a Sprint just by
Caption: what you can run a Sprint by just
Caption: applying a label to that issue for
Caption: Sprint one and then just filtering to
Caption: those labels it's not the best way to
Caption: work
Caption: so we've got issues sorry we've got
Caption: GitHub projects now GitHub projects is
Caption: new
Caption: um if you have used GitHub projects in
Caption: the past you might have used the the
Caption: Legacy projects which we've now
Caption: deprecated there is a really nice
Caption: migration path from the old projects to
Caption: the new projects
Caption: Mitch just did a video on that really
Caption: recently I don't know how where we've
Caption: probably published it on YouTube
Caption: on Instagram today there we go
Caption: and so I'm going to create a new project
Caption: uh
Caption: I'm going to go to the organization to
Caption: create a project
Caption: uh
Caption: new project
Caption: I would call it DDD Perth now I can
Caption: choose one of the templates for these
Caption: projects or I can just go from scratch
Caption: I'm just going to go from scratch just
Caption: to show you how powerful this is
Caption: and I'm going to add the issues from my
Caption: repository so to do that
Caption: by the way we're looking at the table
Caption: View at the moment
Caption: to add an issue I choose my repository
Caption: uh it's haikus for code spaces and then
Caption: I'm just gonna choose
Caption: yeah that one
Caption: so now I have that issue in there
Caption: this thing's hurting me
Caption: um
Caption: and I can add
Caption: left click
Caption: we've also made this quite like keyboard
Caption: friendly so I'm just kind of hitting
Caption: enter and it's taking the top one each
Caption: time just to fill them out
Caption: and we've now got this list of you know
Caption: issues that we're working with we've got
Caption: our columns we've got assignees we've
Caption: got the status of those issues as well
Caption: now status is something that belongs to
Caption: the board
Caption: um so by default you get to do in
Caption: progress and done but I can change those
Caption: statuses I can have whatever statuses I
Caption: want but I can also have custom fields
Caption: in here
Caption: so I can say I want to see the labels
Caption: that's great that's pretty useful but I
Caption: want a new field for an estimate
Caption: and then that field type is a number
Caption: and now we have this estimate column as
Caption: well so I'm just going to go and put
Caption: some
Caption: random numbers in that estimate column
Caption: if I can work things
Caption: I'm putting random numbers in because
Caption: this is like a real life demo where
Caption: estimates are totally random anyway
Caption: um
Caption: and then I can obviously do things like
Caption: filter and say I only want to see the
Caption: estimates that are greater than five oh
Caption: keyboard shortcuts up the opposite so
Caption: Ctrl K on windows by the way no come not
Caption: Windows K and I can filter by
Caption: you know
Caption: um
Caption: what do we go estimate and just say it
Caption: has to be greater than five and it'll
Caption: filter based on those so we can do that
Caption: we can Group by the statuses grouped by
Caption: the labels uh let's Group by actually we
Caption: need another field here for
Caption: um Sprint
Caption: and this is actually a iteration type
Caption: and it starts today iterations go for
Caption: two weeks so in the background it's
Caption: created some iterations for me based on
Caption: every two weeks and I can assign these
Caption: to these Sprints as we go as well so
Caption: yeah let's do that
Caption: and then we'll
Caption: grouped by these
Caption: so now we've got all of our Sprint one
Caption: Sprint two Sprint three and then the
Caption: ones that haven't been
Caption: haven't been done yet
Caption: so we got this like nice little table
Caption: view the other thing we might want to do
Caption: though is have like a Sprint board right
Caption: so let's create a new view
Caption: and this view is going to be
Caption: a board View
Caption: and so now we have our
Caption: board for all the ones with no status so
Caption: by default it's kind of given me the
Caption: status so to do doing done none of these
Caption: have a status so I obviously want some
Caption: of them over here
Caption: but actually this is my Sprint board so
Caption: I'm gonna filter by
Caption: filter by
Caption: Sprint
Caption: and then just say
Caption: the current Sprint
Caption: so you can say you know this is the
Caption: current Sprint or the previous Sprint or
Caption: the next Sprint you can even say current
Caption: plus two or previous minus one or
Caption: something like that which is pretty
Caption: handy and then you can work with these
Caption: these Sprint boards as well you can
Caption: change what's on the cards
Caption: I mean this is a demo that I could spend
Caption: hours and hours on if I could work the
Caption: mouse
Caption: um one thing to note as well is that
Caption: these projects are
Caption: at the organization level
Caption: so we understand that you might have
Caption: issues across a number of different
Caption: repos
Caption: for a project especially if you have a
Caption: microservices situation where you have a
Caption: different repo for your different
Caption: services but you want this roll-up view
Caption: of all of the things that are going on
Caption: at the moment
Caption: so at the org level you have a project
Caption: and you pull in the issues that you care
Caption: about for that project across the
Caption: different repositories or maybe pull in
Caption: the pull requests because you care about
Caption: them as well so issues and pull requests
Caption: can appear here
Caption: um
Caption: you can also have the same issue in
Caption: multiple projects and those projects can
Caption: have different custom Fields so here
Caption: I've got a bunch of work that's going on
Caption: maybe my managers want a different view
Caption: of all of the epics in my organization
Caption: across multiple projects and they also
Caption: have some Fields they want to track like
Caption: maybe they just want a current status of
Caption: red green and yellow or something like
Caption: that that extra field belongs to that
Caption: project and the issue can set you know
Caption: that value on the project so you can
Caption: have different views of the same
Caption: information the great thing about this
Caption: though is you can absolutely customize
Caption: this for however you want you don't need
Caption: to you know you're not stuck in the way
Caption: that GitHub thinks you should run a
Caption: project you can do it any way you want
Caption: the one thing I didn't show you in this
Caption: which I love is that you can also put in
Caption: draft issues so I can add one here to
Caption: say
Caption: um I don't know get a new laptop
Caption: there's a theme for these issues by the
Caption: way and this is a draft issue because it
Caption: doesn't belong to a repository yet it
Caption: just belongs to this project
Caption: we have teams in GitHub who use
Caption: basically nothing but draft issues they
Caption: do everything as draft issues and it's
Caption: only when they actually need to do the
Caption: work that they will convert to an issue
Caption: and then it will ask you what repository
Caption: you want that issue in because it has to
Caption: belong to a repository at that stage
Caption: so look I could I could go on and on
Caption: about all of this sort of stuff
Caption: um before I move on to kind of moving on
Caption: from the planning any questions about
Caption: stuff that I haven't shown you on here
Caption: anyone want to give me a laptop
Caption: and staying down okay
Caption: so look this is also free for everybody
Caption: um we don't charge anything for GitHub
Caption: projects so your own repositories you
Caption: can do it or your own organizations your
Caption: own accounts you can have projects as
Caption: well anything you anything you like
Caption: there's no extra money for this there's
Caption: some other features that I didn't show
Caption: you as well to do with like workflows
Caption: um so when a an issue sorry when an
Caption: issue gets dragged into the done column
Caption: then market is closed in the repo and
Caption: things like that I'm sorry other way
Caption: around
Caption: um a bunch of things like that there's
Caption: more coming to workflows as well there's
Caption: also insights that is I don't know if
Caption: it's
Caption: public preview yet I think it's in the
Caption: public beta insights so you can do your
Caption: burn down charts or burn up accumulative
Caption: flow diagrams or the management manager
Caption: stuff as well
Caption: somebody from GitHub in the back is
Caption: looking at me like I don't know if
Caption: that's public
Caption: Johnson's dog
Caption: yeah
Caption: so at org level for the oh yeah okay
Caption: there we go so the burn up charts and
Caption: stuff are at the
Caption: um Enterprise right or Global burn up
Caption: chance yeah
Caption: cool
Caption: awesome all right let's go back to this
Caption: code and we're going to do some of this
Caption: work all right so uh I don't know if
Caption: anybody here had the same experience as
Caption: me with my first Dev job is it took
Caption: literally about a month before I could
Caption: actually write code on the code base
Caption: because they had to find me a computer
Caption: and then I had to set that computer up
Caption: with the standard operating environment
Caption: and then the project I was on had these
Caption: other dependencies that I needed in
Caption: there as well so you know time to
Caption: actually writing the first code or
Caption: making the first commit was long right
Caption: which is a problem especially if you are
Caption: on multiple projects I don't know if
Caption: anybody's skipped from one project to
Caption: another and there's this period of how
Caption: do I get all this stuff working they're
Caption: using different versions of the
Caption: dependencies all that kind of stuff
Caption: it's also bad for open source and for
Caption: contributing to other projects inner
Caption: source is a problem as well so I know
Caption: when I worked at Microsoft everyone at
Caption: Microsoft every engineer at Microsoft
Caption: has access to almost every repository
Caption: every code base
Caption: and you're encouraged if you find
Caption: something that you need in somebody
Caption: else's code base to submit a pull
Caption: request like to to actually go and
Caption: change it look at their code see how it
Caption: works which is great except I can't
Caption: debug that because they've got this huge
Caption: list of dependencies I can't get that
Caption: working it's not worth my time so I just
Caption: don't do it
Caption: enter code spaces so code spaces is a
Caption: Dev environment in the cloud that's
Caption: targeted at a specific repository so you
Caption: basically have the definition of what's
Caption: required to write code for a project
Caption: defined alongside the code for that
Caption: project
Caption: um before before code space as well if
Caption: you just want to make a small change you
Caption: don't need to do any debugging or
Caption: anything like that just in case anybody
Caption: hasn't seen this before this is in every
Caption: repository if you hit the dot button
Caption: presuming it's the same on a different
Caption: laptop the full stop button dot button
Caption: period whatever you want to call it
Caption: on any GitHub repo even if it's not
Caption: yours
Caption: it'll open the web editor which is
Caption: basically Visual Studio code running in
Caption: your browser so there's no compute on
Caption: the back end in this case it's just
Caption: running inside your browser
Caption: and
Caption: you can make changes to the code you can
Caption: not debug but you can submit a code
Caption: change you can submit a pull request you
Caption: can do all of that kind of stuff
Caption: um
Caption: yeah so you can make small changes I
Caption: actually use this constantly like if I
Caption: need to make a small change to a readme
Caption: or something like that I'll just hit dot
Caption: open it up in here
Caption: this is also really really good for code
Caption: reviews so if somebody submits a pull
Caption: request and you go to the pull request
Caption: page and hit the dot you're brought to
Caption: visual studio code to the web editor or
Caption: web-based editor
Caption: uh in the context of looking at that
Caption: pull request
Caption: so you can see the changes you can see
Caption: what was committed uh the files that are
Caption: different and you can leave comments and
Caption: say this looks good if you have
Caption: permissions you can even merge those
Caption: pull requests in the context of a visual
Caption: studio code instance so you can see the
Caption: library as you can see all the files you
Caption: can see everything like that
Caption: but like I said what you can't do here
Caption: unfortunately
Caption: is
Caption: debug
Caption: especially if you don't know the
Caption: shortcut keys so there's no terminal
Caption: because there's no compute in the
Caption: background I can't do any run and debug
Caption: stuff because there's no compute in the
Caption: background
Caption: um and obviously in the real world you
Caption: need to do that stuff so code spaces is
Caption: basically the same as this except it has
Caption: compute it's a cloud-based Dev
Caption: environment
Caption: um now because we're short on time
Caption: normally I'd create a new one to show
Caption: you how how quickly this works but if
Caption: you go to the code button here and then
Caption: go to code spaces
Caption: uh and I've got one here which is not
Caption: clean that's great
Caption: you know what I'm just going to create a
Caption: new code space
Caption: so you can see how fast it is
Caption: um
Caption: so what it is doing is it's spinning up
Caption: a container in the cloud that's running
Caption: on a machine that has whatever resources
Caption: I need to give it there are a number of
Caption: sizes for these code spaces as well so
Caption: you can do you know two core machines up
Caption: to I think it's 32 core if you ask us
Caption: nicely
Caption: um I think by default you can do
Caption: anything up to 32 core machines I
Caption: believe
Caption: and they get charged basically per
Caption: minute like so they get charged based on
Caption: usage
Caption: um the good thing as well is if you
Caption: leave them uh like you you log out and
Caption: you don't do anything you don't stop
Caption: them they'll stop themselves after a
Caption: period of time I think by default it's
Caption: 20 or 30 minutes it'll stop itself we
Caption: did an internal survey because fun story
Caption: GitHub GitHub so github.com which is a
Caption: mono repo which is about 11 gig of code
Caption: we do github.com entirely in codespaces
Caption: so we use this internally for our own
Caption: gigantic repo using some features like
Caption: pre-builds so we can that's good
Caption: um
Caption: so using some features like pre-builds
Caption: we can get the speed of like starting a
Caption: new code space up sorry down to really
Caption: really small
Caption: um small numbers so if this works
Caption: um I'll show you that in a sec but
Caption: for github.com 11 gig code base about 23
Caption: gig on disk if you do a deep clone it
Caption: takes about I think it's about 10
Caption: seconds 10 12 seconds to go from
Caption: clicking the button to being able to
Caption: debug the code with multiple containers
Caption: running different services in a
Caption: debugging environment and you can commit
Caption: code and do that work straight away it's
Caption: super powerful and it also means if
Caption: somebody new joins the team they're just
Caption: create a new code space and they can
Caption: write code immediately if you start
Caption: working on a different project
Caption: and they have code spaces set up there
Caption: you can go to that other project start a
Caption: code space and now you have this brand
Caption: new Dev machine that's targeted
Caption: specifically at
Caption: um at that repository and at that code
Caption: base
Caption: so here we go uh we are in
Caption: and this is my little application uh
Caption: let's see if I can run it in debug
Caption: it's a node app so I'll choose node
Caption: and remember this is all running just
Caption: um through my browser I don't have this
Caption: code base on this machine on this laptop
Caption: at all not just
Caption: yeah not just for the obvious reasons uh
Caption: that it's not my laptop
Caption: this actually makes the demo kind of
Caption: cool right
Caption: um you know I don't have the code on
Caption: here because it's not my machine but I'm
Caption: still able to to you know do the work to
Caption: write the code so this is what the
Caption: application looks like
Caption: if I go back into my code space again in
Caption: the browser and I find
Caption: file let's find index.js
Caption: get rid of that and then I'll put a
Caption: break point on that render
Caption: and refresh
Caption: and in my other browser tab I've hit
Caption: this breakpoint and you get all of the
Caption: nice stuff that you would normally get
Caption: debugging in a vs code instance
Caption: um on somebody else's computer or on a
Caption: Raspberry Pi wherever you are right
Caption: so pretty cool pretty cool stuff I was
Caption: going to do a tiny little co-pilot demo
Caption: but instead you should go and go to Mrs
Caption: talk uh at 3 15 I think where she's
Caption: going to do co-pilot entirely but I was
Caption: going to like randomize those haikus but
Caption: I don't remember how to do it so I would
Caption: do something like yeah I need to install
Caption: copilot so I'm not going to do it just
Caption: ask copilot to tell me how to randomize
Caption: in node because I don't know
Caption: right so that's code spaces it's super
Caption: powerful you can also connect remotely
Caption: from a visual studio code instance on
Caption: your local machine if you want to
Caption: um you can stop them start them
Caption: disconnect and have multiple running at
Caption: the same time
Caption: so if you are doing some work for one
Caption: particular branch of your code you can
Caption: have a code space open for that and
Caption: another one for the main one and so on
Caption: um and as I said Dev stop themselves if
Caption: you're not using them we did a little
Caption: survey internally for GitHub GitHub to
Caption: find out how often people
Caption: um
Caption: how often people actually stopped the
Caption: code spaces themselves or how often they
Caption: just like
Caption: turn their computer off and waited for
Caption: it to stop itself and it was uh
Caption: approximately there might be a little
Caption: bit of counting error approximately a
Caption: hundred percent of people didn't turn it
Caption: off they just let it expire
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah so one yeah that's a very good
Caption: point I overheard there which is that's
Caption: because they work at GitHub and they
Caption: don't pay for these which is true I did
Caption: a little back of the envelope
Caption: calculation and if you're running I
Caption: think it's a 16 core machine or
Caption: something like that and you're working
Caption: eight hours a day of 50 weeks a year or
Caption: 48 weeks a year or something like that
Caption: it's about equivalent to buying a new
Caption: laptop every two years or something like
Caption: that but remember you've got these code
Caption: spaces that you can have
Caption: in all of these different environments
Caption: and they just don't charge you for usage
Caption: when they're shut down so you could have
Caption: 30 projects that you're working on with
Caption: 30 different code spaces that you can
Caption: start working on immediately from any
Caption: laptop you have it doesn't need to be
Caption: new you should definitely have the
Caption: newest best laptop though that's a good
Caption: idea
Caption: yeah
Caption: so uh
Caption: I'm running low on time as well so we're
Caption: going to move very quickly to the next
Caption: bit so that's kind of our inner loop
Caption: that's a Dev environment that means that
Caption: I can write my code really quickly I can
Caption: get started on new projects and I don't
Caption: have to worry so much about the hardware
Caption: or the dependencies running on my local
Caption: machine super powerful but then when I
Caption: have made the change how do I get that
Caption: into production and this is one of the
Caption: probably better known features I guess
Caption: of GitHub which is GitHub actions who
Caption: who uses GitHub actions
Caption: okay probably about half the room who's
Caption: heard of GitHub actions like who's aware
Caption: of it the same people
Caption: um
Caption: well now the rest of you have heard
Caption: about it so you can move into the next
Caption: column of using it
Caption: um rather than actually run one of these
Caption: I'm going to show you one I've run
Caption: before
Caption: so uh the great thing about GitHub
Caption: actions is the definition of how to
Caption: build your application and how to deploy
Caption: your application is defined in a yaml
Caption: file that sits alongside your code
Caption: so when somebody clones or Forks your
Caption: repository they know not just what the
Caption: code looks like but what the build
Caption: situation is and what the deployment
Caption: situation is they can see all of that if
Caption: you've got a specific code space
Caption: definition set up so you can customize
Caption: those code spaces in huge ways they also
Caption: know what the dev machine needs to look
Caption: like as well whether you're using Code
Caption: spaces or Dev containers just locally
Caption: you know what it you know everything
Caption: about that project you have the code you
Caption: have the definition of how you're going
Caption: to like write code against it like what
Caption: dependencies you need and then you have
Caption: the definition of how you build it and
Caption: how you deploy it and it's just all
Caption: there in your Repository
Caption: uh this is kind of a more mature looking
Caption: pipeline we've got three stages here I'm
Caption: going to try and zoom in a bit I don't
Caption: think this seems great here there we go
Caption: we've got three stages here
Caption: we've got a build stage which does my
Caption: compilation and we have a deployment
Caption: stage which deploys to Azure in this
Caption: case and then we have a production stage
Caption: now the thing that I've set up with
Caption: production is it knows the production
Caption: environment needs approvals before it
Caption: goes to production
Caption: so by saying in that definition I am
Caption: deploying to production you get this
Caption: protection where it has to pass a bunch
Caption: of rules before it's allowed to go into
Caption: production in this case that rule is I
Caption: need to approve that before it goes into
Caption: production
Caption: you can put other rules in there like
Caption: you can only deploy to this environment
Caption: from these branches of your repository
Caption: so maybe you're doing a branching
Caption: strategy where it's a trunk-based
Caption: development and people do feature
Caption: branches but then they merge back into
Caption: your main branch before it goes out to
Caption: production you want to make sure nobody
Caption: deploys to production from a feature
Caption: Branch right so you can put that
Caption: protection on it as well and nobody can
Caption: actually approve that to go to
Caption: production
Caption: so this went to the staging site it went
Caption: to the production site we've got a track
Caption: of the deployments like the reviews
Caption: sorry who did a review and then we've
Caption: even got the artifacts that were
Caption: produced as well so part of the build
Caption: was packaging everything up and then
Caption: uploading it so the subsequent jobs
Caption: could pull that down and do the work
Caption: actually deployed them as well
Caption: the way these actually physically run is
Caption: on these ones are on GitHub hosted
Caption: Runners so these are agents that
Caption: basically spin up when you when there's
Caption: a job to do it'll download the code or
Caption: do whatever you want it to do
Caption: and then when it's finished it'll tear
Caption: itself down entirely so they're on
Caption: demand kind of hosted Runners you can
Caption: also self-host Runners if you want you
Caption: can run the running the runner
Caption: executable on pretty much any machine
Caption: I've run them on Raspberry Piers too so
Caption: you can actually build your application
Caption: on a Raspberry Pi if you really want to
Caption: don't do that
Caption: um or you can do the GitHub host at ones
Caption: really new to GitHub hosted Runners as
Caption: well is the larger sizes of GitHub
Caption: hosted Runners so for for a very long
Caption: time you didn't get to choose how big
Caption: those Runners were the only way to
Caption: choose how much RAM and all that kind of
Caption: stuff was to do your self-hosted ones
Caption: now for GitHub team I believe and GitHub
Caption: Enterprise Cloud you can set up
Caption: larger hosted Runners to say I want you
Caption: know one with 32 cores and gpus and all
Caption: sorts of stuff
Caption: so uh yeah long-running builds or ones
Caption: that are a bit slow uh you can do use
Caption: hosted Runners for those
Caption: now
Caption: there is a lot that I didn't cover in
Caption: this for several reasons
Caption: um if you want to see any of this stuff
Caption: in a little bit more detail we've got
Caption: demos at the booth we've got an awesome
Caption: demo that was actually written by Aaron
Caption: Powell who is probably in that room
Caption: um which has a code space with multiple
Caption: containers that get run and debug at the
Caption: same time with Azure Cosmos DB emulators
Caption: running in them and the actual device
Caption: that I've the keyboard and mouse is
Caption: connected to is this little Raspberry Pi
Caption: but it's running 32 cores in the
Caption: background and 32 gigs of ram in code
Caption: spaces and things like that we use
Caption: GitHub issues for our prize draw as well
Caption: if you haven't signed up for that so if
Caption: you go to a particular GitHub issue you
Caption: can leave a comment and then we use
Caption: GitHub actions to pull the names from
Caption: the names of the people who commented on
Caption: that issue put them in a file and do
Caption: that as part of the deployment to GitHub
Caption: pages that I also didn't mention which
Caption: is a way you can host your own static
Caption: websites in GitHub so the whole thing
Caption: like kind of fits together until you get
Caption: this end-to-end scenario
Caption: so planning and tracking with GitHub
Caption: issues and GitHub projects code spaces
Caption: for that inner loop of actually doing
Caption: development really quickly and really
Caption: efficiently especially for new people to
Caption: the team and then GitHub actions which
Caption: is an automation platform that kind of
Caption: lets you do your CI CD or kind of any
Caption: other automation as well but
Caption: fantastic for CI CD and we've got most
Caption: of the way around there until we get
Caption: back to issues again which is the
Caption: learning from what's in production
Caption: as I said tons of stuff I didn't see I
Caption: didn't tell you about
Caption: um come over to the booth and ask some
Caption: of us for some demos of the stuff that's
Caption: there and otherwise thanks so much for
Caption: your time
Caption: and thanks Mish for the laptop
Caption: thanks Damian that was really cool
Caption: um so it's off to lunch now everybody uh
Caption: so there's lunchtime sessions commencing
Caption: at 2 35